Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
La crisi climatica, ahimè,
non è più una questione
di un lontano futuro,
ma è una questione del nostro presente.
Dodici anni fa ero una studentessa
a un master di politiche ambientali,
e decisi di fare la tesi
su una questione che allora
sembrava un po' esoterica:
la questione dei profughi climatici,
le persone costrette
a muoversi da casa propria
o per le inondazioni,
o per eventi estremi,
o per siccità, o per
l'innalzamento del mare.
Ecco, allora, 12 anni fa,
c'erano le prime stime:
la Banca Mondiale parlava
di 80 milioni di persone -
che allora sembravano tantissime -
entro il 2050,
se non si fosse fatto niente
per evitare la crisi.
Ecco: quest'anno in Pakistan,
a causa di monsoni eccezionali
anche per quella regione
abbiamo visto 32 milioni
di persone affette,
e che sono state costrette
a spostarsi da casa propria.
La Banca Mondiale parlava di 80 milioni,
in 40 anni, in tutto il mondo;
oggi ne abbiamo visti 32 milioni
in pochi mesi, in un solo Paese.
Qualche proiezione è andata storta.
Del resto anche qui, in Europa,
la BBC, qualche anno fa,
ha fatto alzare l'attenzione
sulla questione della crisi climatica:
ha fatto una puntata
di previsioni meteo finte,
facendo finta di essere nel 2050
e facendo vedere picchi di 40 gradi
nel cuore della Gran Bretagna.
Quest'anno, la BBC
ha ripreso quella puntata -
durante le previsioni del tempo vere! -
e ha detto: ci siamo sbagliati.
40 gradi sono arrivati,
ma sono arrivati quest'anno.
Questo significa che
la scienza ha sbagliato,
ma non sulla verità
scomoda e fondamentale:
il clima sta cambiando,
e sta cambiando a causa
dell'attività umana.
Ha sbagliato sui tempi.
Il clima sta cambiando molto più in fretta
rispetto a quello che ci aspettavamo,
e gli impatti stanno arrivando molto prima
rispetto a quello che ci aspettavamo.
E siamo davanti alla tempesta perfetta:
insieme alla crisi energetica,
e agli effetti di due anni di pandemia,
si vedono quali sono i risultati:
estati più calde,
inverni in certi casi più freddi,
e bollette più care.
Nel cuore della civilissima Europa,
sono 100 milioni le persone
che soffrono di povertà energetica,
duplicate rispetto a qualche anno fa.
100 milioni di persone
che devono scegliere, alla fine del mese,
se accendere il riscaldamento
o mettere il cibo a tavola.
E noi sappiamo molto bene
che queste crisi non colpiscono
tutti allo stesso modo.
Come dice una bellissima campagna
di Fridays For Future:
"Siamo tutti nella stessa tempesta,
ma non siamo tutti nella stessa barca".
La storia della crisi climatica
è una storia di disuguaglianza.
Innanzitutto, appunto,
disuguaglianza tra generazioni.
Qui dietro di me vedete un grafico:
è uno scenario in cui dobbiamo ridurre,
azzerare le emissioni entro il 2050,
che è quello di cui c'è bisogno
per evitare il collasso climatico.
Senza bisogno di troppe spiegazioni,
vedete quanto le generazioni
hanno a disposizione di emissioni,
quanto possono emettere per generazione.
E vedete bene che le generazioni di oggi
hanno molto meno a disposizione;
avranno molto meno impatto sulla crisi,
ma saranno quelli che ne soffriranno
maggiormente le conseguenze.
Sono i nostri figli, sono i nostri nipoti.
Disuguaglianze tra genere:
sembra strano,
ma siccome le donne guadagnano meno,
e sono vittime di discriminazione,
sono meno resilienti
agli impatti della crisi climatica.
Muoiono di più, perdono di più il lavoro
a causa degli impatti.
Disuguaglianze tra classi:
le persone che soffrono di più
gli effetti della crisi climatica
sono per esempio gli anziani soli, poveri,
nelle nostre periferie,
che soffrono le ondate di calore.
Sono le minoranze etniche,
sono le persone che vivono
nelle case popolari
che si ammalano di più
di malattie cardiorespiratorie
dovute all'aria malsana.
E infine, disuguaglianze tra territori:
sono i Paesi che meno sono stati
responsabili della crisi climatica
a soffrirne maggiormente le conseguenze.
Oggi abbiamo parlato del Pakistan,
ma anche l'Uganda, la Nigeria,
il Sudest asiatico, l'America Latina.
Ahimè, non siamo davanti
a un film catastrofista di Hollywood:
è la realtà.
E non siamo neanche davanti
a un film thriller:
non dobbiamo aspettare la fine del film
per sapere chi sono
i colpevoli, i responsabili.
In questi mesi ho sentito -
in particolare, dopo il crollo
della Marmolada -
passare un po' la narrazione
per cui siamo un po' tutti colpevoli
della crisi climatica.
Ecco, non è vero.
È il modo migliore per atterrire,
per farci sentire in colpa,
per fermare il cambiamento.
La crisi climatica ha dei responsabili,
che hanno dei nomi e cognomi.
I primi sono le fonti fossili,
e chi negli anni le ha estratte,
distribuite e vendute,
sapendo benissimo
quali fossero le conseguenze,
facendolo lo stesso
e facendo dei profitti enormi.
Ma oggi noi sappiamo che quelle fonti
non sono solo le più sporche,
le più malsane per il pianeta
e per noi stessi;
ma anche le più instabili,
le più volatili, le più costose.
Pensate a quello che sta succedendo oggi
nelle nostre bollette di casa.
Le rinnovabili sono molto più presenti:
ma chi determina il prezzo
dell'elettricità,
e quindi chi ha un impatto
sulle nostre bollette,
è il gas.
Il secondo responsabile
è la disuguaglianza.
E voi vi chiederete:
ma perché la disuguaglianza?
Ho capito che gli impatti sono diversi,
ma addirittura che causa
la crisi climatica?
Sta esagerando.
Io lo capisco bene che ve lo chiediate,
perché per anni le questioni
della crisi climatica
sono state dipinte come appannaggio
di un'élite privilegiata,
un po' radical chic:
la sciura che va in centro in bicicletta,
la ricca new age che mangia tofu.
Ecco: non c'è cosa più sbagliata
di dipingerla così.
Non sono i miliardari che stanno adottando
stili di vita sostenibili.
Anzi, è proprio il contrario.
Il motivo per cui oggi è così difficile
evitare il collasso climatico
è per l'aumento sfrenato
del consumo di lusso di pochissimi.
Recentemente, è uscito un rapporto
che dimostra che i dati sono chiari:
se noi guardiamo
alle emissioni pro capite,
quanto ognuno di noi consuma,
emette, inquina,
sì: sono aumentate
del due percento, dal 1990.
Ma chi le ha fatte aumentare?
L'un percento della popolazione
le ha aumentate di quasi il 30%;
E lo 0,01% della popolazione,
una manciata di individui -
sono quasi tutti uomini -
le ha aumentate del quasi 80%.
Mentre le classi medie, noi,
le abbiamo addirittura diminuite,
e diminuite di quasi il 15%.
E quindi, il motivo
per cui è così difficile
evitare la crisi climatica,
il motivo per cui non stiamo diminuendo
le emissioni come dovremmo,
non è perché stanno
aumentando le popolazioni
nei paesi del Sud del mondo,
perché dobbiamo provvedere cibo
ed energia alle persone;
ma perché aumentano gli stili
di vita insostenibili
di una piccolissima
fetta della popolazione.
E quindi che si fa?
Vi ho riempito di notizie cattive,
adesso comincio con quelle buone.
La prima buona notizia
è che la cosiddetta transizione ecologica,
di cui avrete sentito tanto parlare -
cambiare radicalmente
i nostri sistemi industriali,
di produzione, sociali,
economici, politici,
per dimezzare le emissioni
nei prossimi otto anni
e azzerarle nei prossimi 30 -
ecco, la transizione ecologica
ha molti più benefici
rispetto al cosiddetto
"business as usual",
rispetto al fare come si è sempre fatto,
rispetto a investire nei fossili.
Vi faccio solo un esempio:
tutti i rapporti, tutti i dati nel mondo
ci dicono che il numero di posti di lavoro
creati investendo nelle rinnovabili
e nell'efficientamento energetico
sono di più
rispetto a quelli che si potrebbero avere
investendo nei fossili:
il 50% in più, secondo alcune ricerche.
E questo vale per l'aria pulita,
per tutti i benefici della transizione.
Quindi, se c'è questa enorme opportunità,
se la transizione ecologica
è questa enorme opportunità,
qual è la sfida?
La sfida è far sì che questi benefici
vadano veramente a chi ne ha più bisogno,
e che la transizione venga pagata
da chi ne ha di più.
Sembra buon senso, o socialismo?
Decidete voi.
Ma è esattamente quello
che Alexander Langer diceva
prima di morire:
"La transizione ecologica,
per essere efficace,
deve essere socialmente desiderabile".
O deve essere giusta, come chiede
il Movimento Mondiale dei sindacati.
E come si fa, cosa
vuol dire, concretamente?
Ecco: la seconda buona notizia
è che per capire cosa vuol dire
questa cosa concretamente
basta andare a vedere
chi la sta già facendo.
Perché ci sono persone
che la stanno già facendo,
e normalmente sono nelle città.
Prima cosa, vuol dire eliminare
la povertà energetica,
di cui si parlava prima,
e mettere al centro la casa.
La casa è la politica ambientale,
economica e sociale
migliore che si possa fare,
come sta facendo la sindaca
Ada Colau a Barcellona:
ha ridotto in pochi anni del 19%
i costi energetici delle famiglie,
accelerando l'efficientamento energetico
e cominciando innanzitutto
dalle case popolari.
E creando una rete di advisor,
di operatori sociali -
che già erano formati per prendersi carico
delle persone più povere -
e li ha formate
sulle questioni energetiche,
in modo tale che potessero aiutare
le persone anziane, sole,
le famiglie povere,
a rendere le proprie case più efficienti
e a ridurre le bollette.
Creando addirittura lavoro verde,
nel welfare e nel settore di cura.
Significa, come stanno facendo in Ghana,
significa creare posti di lavoro verde:
ma soprattutto, far sì
che le persone che ne hanno più bisogno
abbiano accesso a questi posti di lavoro,
e farlo con i lavoratori.
In Ghana, ad Accra,
gli ultimi due sindaci hanno aumentato
la raccolta differenziata del 10%.
E in particolare nelle zone più povere,
hanno migliorato
i propri sistemi di rifiuti
e l'hanno fatto coinvolgendo
i cosiddetti raccoglitori informali,
quelle persone che normalmente
vivono sulle discariche,
raccogliendo rifiuti qua e di là
e poi rivendendoli.
Chiudendo le discariche,
si rischiava di fare del male
a quelle persone,
che così non avrebbero più avuto reddito;
e invece di far sì che quelle persone
potessero diventare oppositori
alle politiche ambientali,
li hanno coinvolti,
e li hanno messi in una cooperativa
e hanno migliorato anche le qualità
di lavoro e di vita
di quelle stesse persone,
facendo una cosa
ambientalmente sostenibile
ma anche socialmente desiderabile.
Terzo, significa far sì
che i servizi che noi usiamo
siano distribuiti in modo equo,
siano accessibili
e i benefici arrivino davvero a tutti.
Come sta facendo, a Jakarta,
questo governatore
che in pochi anni ha duplicato
il trasporto pubblico nella città.
Oggi a Jakarta, che è una città
di milioni e milioni di abitanti.
Il 90% dei suoi abitanti
ha accesso a una forma
di trasporto pubblico sostenibile
entro 500 metri da casa.
E lo ha fatto riducendone i costi:
prima una famiglia a Jakarta pagava
il 30% del proprio reddito sui trasporti;
oggi ne paga il 10%.
Infine, significa -
e forse questa è la cosa
a cui tengo di più -
significa gestire il conflitto.
La transizione ecologica
porterà conflitto,
non farà soddisfatti tutti.
Bisogna saperlo, riconoscerlo e gestirlo,
come ha fatto Parigi
con la sindaca Anne Hidalgo.
Negli stessi anni in cui imperavano
i "Gilets Jaunes" -
ricorderete, quel movimento
di protesta, nato in Francia
a causa di una tassa calata
dall'alto sulla benzina.
Quindi, una misura
ambientalmente sostenibile
ma non socialmente desiderabile.
Negli stessi anni,
Anne Hidalgo chiudeva il centro cittadino,
pedonalizzava la Senna,
riduceva drasticamente le auto
in centro città,
e lo faceva attraverso 15.000 volontari
che andavano a spiegare le misure
ambientalmente più complicate.
E lo faceva con un dialogo serrato
con le case automobilistiche,
a cui ho assistito - non è stato facile -
e lo faceva nelle corti,
facendo la propria battaglia e vincendola.
Oggi, il centro di Parigi
ha una qualità dell'aria migliore,
si respira meglio e si vive meglio.
Ecco: cosa ci dicono questi esempi?
Innanzitutto, ci dicono
che la transizione ecologica
non è, innanzitutto, una questione tecnica
e di innovazione tecnologica.
Spesso, la tecnologia c'è già.
È una questione, soprattutto,
di innovazione sociale,
di innovazione di processo,
di innovazione delle politiche,
di innovazione su come
prendere le decisioni
e dei rapporti di forza
che decidiamo di mettere in campo.
Non dobbiamo aspettare
il messia della téchne,
bisogna semplicemente agire qui ed ora
ed avere il coraggio di innovare.
E la terza e ultima buona notizia
è che abbiamo ancora tempo.
Secondo gli scienziati sul clima
di tutto il mondo,
il tempo per evitare
il collasso climatico c'è:
è poco, sono otto anni
per dimezzare le emissioni,
ma il tempo c'è.
E per farlo, serve davvero tutto.
La crisi climatica
ha dei responsabili chiari,
ma la sfida è tale per cui nessuno
si può chiamare indietro.
Ma non, appunto, per senso di colpa;
ma per davvero partecipare
a una delle più straordinarie
occasioni di cambiamento
che l'umanità ha davanti collettivamente.
Non è facile far ridere con i temi
della transizione ecologica,
ma vi assicuro: può essere una figata,
se lo facciamo tutti.
Qualche settimana fa ero a Buenos Aires,
al summit che l'organizzazione
per la quale lavoro
organizza con i sindaci della rete.
E lì c'era forse,
tra tutti i sindaci con cui ho avuto
il piacere e l'onore di lavorare,
c'era il sindaco
di Los Angeles, Eric Garcetti,
forse quello che ha ispirato maggiormente
il mio percorso professionale,
che raccontava cosa si stava
facendo a Los Angeles:
una moratoria sulle trivellazioni,
tramite un fondo per i lavoratori,
una task force sulla transizione
giusta, tante cose belle.
E raccontava appunto, anche,
che a Los Angeles c'è Hollywood,
c'è il settore del cinema,
che è un settore che può dire la sua
sulle questioni della transizione.
E oggi, effettivamente,
abbiamo parlato di film
e della crisi climatica
come un potenziale film,
di cui sappiamo
i colpevoli, i responsabili.
Sappiamo anche chi sono i protagonisti:
i protagonisti siamo tutti noi,
con i nostri comportamenti individuali;
sono i media, e come raccontano,
come decidono di raccontare questa storia;
sono gli attivisti, che scendono in piazza
insieme alla società civile;
è la politica, con le
grandi trasformazioni;
chi fa cultura; chi educa, appunto;
chi investe; le imprese,
che decidono dove investire,
e su cosa disinvestire soprattutto.
Siamo tutti noi.
L'unica cosa che non conosciamo
di questo film è la fine.
Ecco: lo spoiler che vi faccio
è che la fine può essere lieta,
esattamente come i film di Hollywood.
Eric Garcetti diceva che siamo davanti
a una grande rivoluzione potenziale.
Vogliamo guardarla, come se fosse un film,
o vogliamo farla?
Grazie.
(Applausi)